[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là l'occasion de la journée
mobilité sur le cycle de paix à paris
saclay afin de présenter alors nous de
l'autre côté une borne de recharge que
nous installons sur le site de l'opéra
donc boom qui fonctionne en autopartage
et
que nous avons 80 80 bornes à installer
en fait sur la zone sur cette borne
il ya deux points de charge 22 kg et
avec un câble qui sera attaché qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas présent puisqu'on
est là en démonstration et cette borne
permettra donc de recharger en fonction
de la capacité des véhicules de
recharger plus ou moins rapidement les
bornes alors certains de nos voitures
seront en autopartage et permettront de
naviguer dans la zone de bornes en
bornes en fonction des usages
aujourd'hui les plombs est en cours les
premières bornes ont été installées il
ya peu de temps et elle devrait être
accordé dans les semaines qui arrivent
et ce projet est prévu aussi sur 2019
le pea pas me traiter en tant
qu'aménageur aménage doute le campus
urbain sur la zac de polytechnique et de
palaiseau et il se doit d'accompagner
l'arrivée progressive mais massive
d'usagé et de développer des quartiers
de vie attractif et à ce titre là le
père également compétent pour déployer
les premiers services de mobilité
partagée entre tous ces acteurs
justement pour faciliter les synergies
et les déplacements sur le campus et
avec une ambition d'excellence
environnementale le pea paris sacré à
bénéficier des aides à l'investissement
durant le cadre du programme thé pcv
pour la transition écologique qui lui a
permis d'investir dans le premier réseau
de bornes de recharge électrique du
plateau de saclay et donc ces bornes
sont en cours de déploiement à la fois
sur des espaces publics les que sur les
communes de palaiseau hors cei vif mais
également sur des espaces privés
d'établissements comme le cea le cnrs
l'université paris sud
[Musique]